Про мітинги сепаратистів та вуличні бої навесні 2014 року в Маріуполі нині нагадують
лише спалена міська рада та зруйнована будівля управління поліції.
Шість років потому півмільйонне місто на Азовському морі оговталось від війни,
а політичні баталії тут ведуться не зі зброєю в руках, а на білбордах.
Фаворит на виборах міського голови у Маріуполі - чинний мер міста Вадим Бойченко.
До обрання у 2015 році він працював топменеджером на Металургійному комбінаті імені Ілліча,
який входить у групу "Метінвест" олігархів Ріната Ахметова і Вадима Новинського.
У місті Вадим Бойченко - фігура вкрай популярна.
Інфраструктура, більшість доріг стали кращими, є взагалі дуже добрі дороги.
Парки будуються - є куди піти.
Поліція - жирні дядьки з жезлами більше не стоять за кущами і не вимагають штрафи. Зміни є.
Хотілося б, щоб екологія трохи покращилась.
За ці 4-5 років у місті відбулися зміни на краще, багато будується,
але хотілося б, щоб і в екології був прогрес.
У нас маленька дитина, тому ця тема нас дуже турбує.
За останні 5 років місто дуже змінилося. Напевно, зроблено двічі більше, ніж за останні 20 років.
Це точно. Єдине, чого хотілося б, - це екологічності.
У Маріуполі розташовані одразу два металургійні гіганти - комбінати імені Ілліча та "Азовсталь",
що належать до найбільших забруднювачів повітря в Україні. Утім, тему екології партія мера воліє уникати.
Натомість хизується інфраструктурними досягненнями -
відремонтованими дорогами, сучасним транспортом та парками.
Які важелі має місцева влада, щоб впливати на промислові підприємства - можете мені сказати?
Їх немає. Є державна екологічна інспекція, є законодавці, які прописали закони так,
що місцева влада не має важелів впливу на бізнес, що стосується природоохоронних заходів і так далі.
Тим часом політичні опоненти чинного мера стверджують, що важелі впливу на забруднювачів у міської влади є.
Приміром, можна було б підвищити ставку податку на постійне користування землею для підприємств-забруднювачів,
доки вони не завершать екологічну модернізацію.
А бездіяльність міської влади у цій сфері пояснюють залежністю від Ріната Ахметова.
Щоправда, у команді мера Маріуполя це заперечують.
Натомість у партії "Сила Людей", яка об'єднала екоактивістів і на виборах у 2015 році отримала декілька місць у міській раді,
вважають, що небезпека олігархічного впливу на міську владу виходить за рамки екології.
Монополія - це завжди погано. Мономісто - це завжди погано.
Припустимо, що сьогодні Ахметову місто Маріуполь цікаве і у нас будують парки, дороги.
Але що з нами буде завтра?Якщо щось трапиться завтра, то все зупиниться. Ну, перестане воно цікавити його.
Сьогодні ми розуміємо, що він хоче з Маріуполя зробити такий міні-Донецьк.
Цікава іграшка, в якій були б гарні газони, тротуари і дороги.
Але що робити малому та середньому бізнесу, якщо все монополізоване?
Звідси просто будуть їхати люди. У нас зараз де можна працювати?
Лише на заводах, водієм трамваїв, тролейбусів, в комунальних підприємствах - тут вакансії є.
Попри критику політичних опонентів, у місті металургів чинний мер Вадим Бойченко має велику підтримку
- за нього готові проголосувати близько семидесяти відсотків виборців.
Донедавна Бойченко вважався представником "Опозиційного блоку"
- на вибори до Верховної Ради торік він ішов під номером 5 у списку цієї політичної сили.
Утім, особистий рейтинг мера в Маріуполі перевищив популярність "Опозиційного блоку"
- і у місті було створено партію імені його самого.
А фракцію "Опоблоку" у міській раді перейменували на "Блок Вадима Бойченка".
Наскільки це допоможе на виборах - невідомо. Адже на п'яти новій партії наступає ОПЗЖ.
Усі рейтинги, які проводяться, дуже різні - в залежності від того, хто цей рейтинг замовив.
Сто відсотків, що монобільшості у Вадима Сергійовича вже не буде.
Коли в тебе є 49 депутатів, які за вказівкою підіймають руки - такого вже не буде.
У лавах ОПЗЖ багато людей, які працювали за минулої каденції, які працювали з минулим мером.
Можна їх назвати корупціонерами? Мабуть, можна.
І за каденції Вадима Сергійовича їх з роботи вигнали. А зараз вони хочуть реваншу.
Обіцянки на рекламних плакатах "Опозиційної платформи" далекі від комунальної політики.
Передвиборчі гасла ОПЗЖ у Маріуполі радше пасували б до парламентських перегонів.
Проте, за даними різних опитувань, партія кума Путіна Віктора Медведчука на місцевих виборах
у Маріуполі набирає від 20 до понад 40 відсотків - така собі маріупольська соціологія.
Питаємо маріупольців, чи не бачать вони небезпеки реваншу в місті - чи то проросійського, чи то відверто сепаратистського.
Якщо буде помітно, що місцева влада починає діяти в цьому векторі, громадяни не чекатимуть -
вийдуть і скажуть, що вони проти цього.
Я думаю, що Маріуполь чітко дав зрозуміти, що ми - проукраїнське місто.
Громадяни Маріуполя цілком підтримують Україну, і тут не буде ніякого проросійського реваншу.
Всі станемо на захист - я перший. Іншого нам вже не треба. Ми вже звикли до хорошого.
Зараз тут комфортно жити. Дай Боже, щоб так продовжувалося і в майбутньому.
Не хочеться, щоб було, як у Донецьку та Луганську.
Від Маріуполя до війни - нині лише 10 кілометрів по прямій. А у 2014 році так звана "сіра зона"
- тобто ніким не контрольована територія - взагалі починалася вже просто за містом.
На передові позиції української армії у селі Широкине їдемо з військовим волонтером Альбертом Хомяком.
Оптимізму інших маріупольців щодо майбутніх виборів він не поділяє.
Усі ми знаємо, що Медведчук - проросійський політик, він кум Путіна.
Вони намагатимуться змінити думку місцевого населення в тому сенсі, що зближення з Росією
- це нині найкращий вихід для України. У Росії все-таки є амбіції не тільки заволодіти Маріуполем,
але й прокласти собі шлях до Криму. А для цього потрібно мати вплив у місцевій громаді.
Адже ми пам'ятаємо, як у 2014 році все починалося - "так люди хочуть, треба дотримуватися думки людей".
Я дуже люблю фільм про Буратіно - "на дурака не нужен нож, ему немного подпоешь - и делай с ним, что хошь"…
Наприкінці січня 2015 року терористи "ДНР" обстріляли Маріуполь з реактивної артилерії - тоді загинули десятки людей.
Невдовзі після цього українські сили розпочали наступ і відсунули лінію фронту від міста.
Нині село Широкине - форпост України на шляху до Маріуполя. Колись популярний морський курорт лежить у руїнах та нагадує… Прип'ять.
Навіть у тому сенсі, що і в Прип'яті, і тут було місце героїзму.
Військовий каже, шо у Широкиному нині не стріляють. Утім, і повного перемир'я немає.
Їхні дрони як літали - так і літають. Вони і далі продовжують укріплювати інженерні позиції.
На даний час Маріуполь не в небезпеці - хоча б тому, що ми його обороняємо. І ми вже нікуди звідси не підемо.
Але в принципі будь-якої ситуації виключати не можна,
адже ми маємо справу з дуже віроломним і непередбачуваним противником.
Про те, що Росії не можна довіряти, - особисто я це зрозумів ще в Криму.
У 2015 році озвучувалися плани щодо демілітаризації Широкиного.
Утім, мешканці Маріуполя вийшли на протести проти виводу українських військ зі стратегічних позицій
між містом і підконтрольною бойовикам територією.
Нині у Маріуполі - мирне життя, а мітингують тут на підтримку білоруської опозиції
Утім, запевняють маріупольські активісти, на вулицю вийдуть і проти будь-яких спроб реваншу сепаратистів.